Okay. So we have to spend some time today
talking about the general election in the
United Kingdom late last year, last week
because there is so much being said about
it and how it does or doesn't relate to the
upcoming 2020 election here in the United
States and Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders.
And there's a lot of interesting and good
thoughtful takes about this, but there's also
some bad talking points and misinformation
that's being spread. So let's start with the
facts. What happened in the UK? Trump Aeon,
conservative party, prime minister Boris Johnson
won with the Tories, the right wing party,
getting a majority of 80 seats in the house
of commons. This truly is huge and it's especially
huge because the Tories had just lost the
majority back in 2017 and then meanwhile a
crushing defeat for the labor party and its
prime minister candidate then leader who has
since resigned, Jeremy Corbyn major losses,
ended up with the lowest proportion of seats
since 1935 did the labor party, but a brutal
defeat.
I mean that's the only way I can really characterize
it. In Jeremy Corbyn has resigned as the head
of the labor party now. Meanwhile, the Scottish
national party won a huge victory in Scotland
winning 48 of 59 seats. That has some interesting
relationships to the Scottish independence
movement, the Brexit and the view of Brexit
in Scotland, and there's a lot to discuss
there as well. So let's go through it in pieces.
Was this a landslide for the right in the
United Kingdom? It was, absolutely. Is it
a crushing defeat for labor considering that
it is sort of the closest to the modern American
progressive movement of Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren? It is absolutely a crushing
defeat for labor in the UK, but this is where
a lot of the analyses started to start to
go off the rails because when we think further,
there are people saying this is a signal.
What happened in the UK is a signal that there
is a rejection of the Bernie Warren ideology
and policy prescriptions happening worldwide
and it signals that someone with Bernie or
Warren's platforms here in the United States
will get crushed in 2020 Trump is going to
win. The Democrats would be very, very wrong
to go with someone like Bernie Sanders or
Elizabeth Morton because they can't win as
proven by the defeat of labor in the U K this
analysis is too simplistic, so let's try to
flush it out a little bit and look at it more
closely. First of all, the starting point
in the UK is a much stronger social democracy
then we have here in the United States. When
you look at the institutions that they already
have, for example, the UK already has nationalized
healthcare, the NHS. Now I know that there
are some ideas of Boris Johnson dismantling
it, but the point is they've had it for a
long time.
It is popular. Voting for labor is not how
you might get such a system of nationalized
healthcare. They have it. Similarly on education
in the UK, on other safety nets and so many
other areas. These policies are already part
of British society. So when you realize that
they already have these things, labor, there
is not like Bernie or Warren here because
here the left is trying to get lots of things
for the first time that the U K already has.
So the stakes are very different and therefore,
comparing what happened to labor in the UK
to a Bernie Warren candidacy or presidency
or nomination on the democratic side here
is not an apt comparison in that way in the
United States. The people offering a lot of
those programs that are already part of British
society are the left most of those running
in the democratic party. Whereas in the U
K many of these programs have been in place
for decades.
So labor being brutally defeated in the UK,
which they were, doesn't confirm that the
policy of Bernie Warren social Democrats is
doomed to fail in the United States. Now,
that gets us to labor as a specific group
of people. Jeremy Corbyn as a person versus
Bernie Warren, et cetera. Having a candidate
who was dogged by allegations of coddling
antisemitism, not taking it seriously, having
unsavory characters in their coalition and
who was seen as flacid in his responses was
not good. Now, we don't need to argue about
each claim related to antisemitism because
I know there are people who say, no, look,
he did this investigation into this antisemitic
allegation. We don't need to argue about it.
I don't want to make this an adjudication
of each claim. You can research it for yourself
without adjudicating each claim. I think we
would all agree that the allegations clouded
labor for a long time and they were not definitively
done away with in the eyes of the voters.
And then further, by the way, right after
this election, former London mayor Ken Livingstone,
who's a former labor party MP who was actually
suspended over antisemitism, came out and
said, I told you labor loss because of the
unhelpful Jewish vote, which is not only insane,
it's also mathematically impossible. There
are roughly 400,000 Jews in the U K that includes
children. That includes, you know, that that's
everybody and Corbyn lost the popular vote
by nearly 4 million votes. So I don't even
know why I have to mention that, but obviously
those types of claims are absurd, but they're
exactly the type of stuff that people are
concerned about. Labor had a cloud over it
that is specific to labor. That being said,
I have pointed out that Bernie's got some
problematic surrogates. Linda Sarsour is one
also dogged with antisemitism in her past.
I think Bernie should separate from her. I
just don't know that that is going to take
Bernie down.
Uh, this narrative has not become a predominant
one in the United States. Elizabeth Warren
had a racist, homophobic, trans black woman
as a surrogate. We called her out. I believe
she has been removed from the Warren campaign.
But what's not being met mentioned in all
of this is Brexit, which is looming over everything
in the U K in a way that it is not here in
the United States. So in addition to the stakes
being different because of the social programs
that the UK already has, in addition to the
cloud over Corbyn being very different than
anything affecting Bernie or Warren right
now, uh, labor's position on Brexit amounted
to maybe, okay, which is a very weak position
and probably didn't help them. So what can
we glean from the UK results? We can't say
Bernie Warren type politicians are dead in
the water because they're not, we can't say
Americans don't want progressive policy on
healthcare and education and corporate reform
because by and large, the polls tell us that
they do.
What we do need to say is what I've been saying
for a year. No matter what the hypothetical
match-ups might say, Trump might absolutely
crush everyone and we need to fight for every
single vote. No constituency can be assumed
to be with us until they go out and vote in
2020 we can confirm that having a policy and
a set of ideas is vastly more important than
a grievance candidate or an anti Trump candidacy.
That I think is a lesson. It was a right wing
landslide in the UK, but it's a cautionary
tale about the 2020 election not assigned
to throw in the towel because Bernie Warren
types are obviously being rejected, different
situation, different electorate, different
status quo and starting point. And the answer
to it all is the same thing that we knew before
the UK election, which is get out the vote,
assume nothing and we will actually have some
interesting polling later that confirms that
all is not well so to speak.
Uh, but more on that coming up a little bit
later